to hear President Trump tell it the next
step he hopes is that Kim jong-un will
start tearing down the nuclear program
he just spent billions building but the
president's critics doubt this new
relationship will ever pay off it was a
moment for the history books the first
time a sitting US president has met with
the leader of North Korea the road to
get here was a long one White House
officials told Fox News the entire
summit was dependent on how the first
one-on-one between the leaders would go
after decades of political and
rhetorical conflict between the two
nations and personal insults they hurled
at each other President Trump says he
and Kim jong-eun formed a personal bond
we're prepared to start a new history
and were ready to write a new chapter
between our nation's the summit ended
with a joint communique Kim pledging to
work toward the complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
in exchange for u.s. security guarantees
the wall will see the major change but
missing from the document any language
about verification the nuts and bolts of
how the US will ensure that Kim is
making good on his promises the
President Trump insisted that will all
be worked out it's going to be achieved
by having a lot of people there and as
we develop a certain trust and we're
going to be working with them on a lot
of other things but this is complete D
nuclearization Democrats jumped on the
communique as vague and toothless Kim
jong-un and North Korea have made
commitments in the past that they have
not followed more specific commitments
than we've heard during the summit so
you can't take his word for it
President Trump also heard criticism for
his pledge to end us south korean joint
military exercises along a thorn in
north korea's side the president calling
them provocative and expensive number
one we saved money a lot and number two
it really is something that i think they
very much appreciated the Trump seems to
have given away two or three of the
major things that Kim jong-un wanted a
meeting the flags next to each other now
no delay of exercises with South Korea
without getting anything in return but
president Trump also found praise from
British Foreign Secretary Boris Johnson
who said in a statement this is an
important step towards the stability of
a region vital to global economic growth
Senator Lindsey Graham says he'd have
given Kim's security guarantees too I'm
a pretty hawkish guy but I want peace I
don't want war I'm willing to give him
security guarantees and economic
opportunity that I didn't think I would
have given a year ago President Trump
says the details of denuclearization
verification and end the war and
possible normalization of relations with
the US will all be worked out in future
meetings with Kim the president's
Republican colleagues are urging him to
proceed cautiously working with him is
like trying to hand feed a shark you can
do it but you have to do it very very
carefully
Democrats also criticize President Trump
for giving Kim jong-un the legitimacy of
a one-on-one meeting with the leader of
the free world
president Trump insists he gave up
nothing other than a couple of days
travel and says he was happy to sit down
with Kim if it would go some distance to
saving the lives of the millions of
people president Trump says would likely
be killed in a nuclear confrontation
between the United States and North
Korea Chris John thank you